- This Monday I went to
my first ever Apple event.
I've never been to an Apple event before,
so I don't know what's gonna happen.
I heard it gets pretty crazy
in there, pretty rowdy.
Here are some things I learned.
(upbeat music)
First of all, I looked a little different
from most people at the event.
People have got on suit jackets.
As you can see, I'm wearing a hat.
They played some damn
good music at this thing.
I feel like this is better
than the club right now.
(dance music)
I'm the only person jamming to it though,
so I'll take it.
This guy Kevin is pretty
bad at drawing a flower,
but pretty good at developing software.
Also, these people really
like their game of thrones.
My man Kevin?
His dog was ready to be picked up.
- And I'm expecting to get a
call to see when he's ready.
- [Voiceove] (mumbles)
- She's like, "Okay,
come pick the dog up."
(laughter)
I'm still a little iffy
when it comes to constant communication.
- You can read full emails.
- [Voiceover] You can mark them unread,
or you can flag them,
or you can delete them.
- Also, Kevin's daughter needs to be
a little bit more responsible.
- Here's one coming in from Maddie.
Saying she's forgot her key
and can't get in the house.
- I mean, he's in the middle
of a presentation girl.
App developers are a bit more cooler
than you would expect.
They're always down on a fist bump,
or compliment you on your hat.
- I love your hat.
It's so cool.
- Thank you so much.
However, you may have
some different opnions
on some things.
- Okay.
- Ready?
One, two, three.
And Photo Booth is still
the best part of a Mac Book.
(loud beeps)
(camera click)
Also, there's now another
way for people to avoid
talking about their feelings.
- And you can even send your heartbeat.
This is an incredibly intimate way
to tell someone you're thinking about 'em.
- Now I don't have to
say I love you anymore.
Also, Shazaam finally got
it's (bleep) together.
- I see the song, the album art.
I can see the lyrics.
- Oh my God, it brings up the lyrics.
It brings up the lyrics.
- Overall I learned that Apple
puts on a pretty good party,
with surprises, thrills, and
a lot of badly drawn sketches.
Oh and by the way, tech bloggers
can be kind of agressive.
Okay?
I almost took a laptop to the head.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Excuse me.
(upbeat pop music)